elon musk is the most recognizable
self-made tech billionaire in the world
today he has been hailed as the real
world tony stark not only is he at the
cutting edge of 21st century technology
but as of this video he is also the
richest man in the world according to
the forbes real-time billionaire list
elon owns approximately 48 of spacex a
company revolutionizing the commercial
space industry and leading the charge to
making human beings a multi-planetary
species he also owns 23 percent of tesla
motors a company that probably needs no
introduction in the last decade musk and
tesla have come to dominate the electric
car market in the last year alone
tesla's market capitalization has grown
from 100 billion us dollars in january
2020 to 1.12 trillion us dollars as of
october 30th 2021 this makes tesla
motors the largest automaker in the
world in terms of valuation surpassing
legacy competitors like toyota
volkswagen ford and bmw combined this
made us think what does elon musk have
to say about his competitors and the
future of the eevee market stick around
as we take a look at some of tesla's
main competitors and musk's opinion
about them toyota and daimler
let's begin with the second largest and
the fifth largest automotive maker on
the valuation list after tesla today it
is hard to imagine that both toyota and
daimler had considerable investments in
tesla during the early days of the
company in 2009 when the company was
almost on its deathbed germany's daimler
ag bought a 10 stake valued at 50
million u.s dollars then again in 2010
toyota invested another 50 million us
dollars in tesla they also sold their
nume factory which is now tesla's
fremont factory at a heavily discounted
price musk has confirmed it in various
talks and interviews over the years that
these early fundings and partnerships
had not only saved tesla but also
propelled the company to a global stage
as you can hear from one of his
interviews in 2010 both partnerships
meant a great deal to elon and tesla you
know such great partners is i think a
strong endorsement of tesla subsequently
both automakers sold their stakes in
tesla for a good profit in 2017 after
the company went public today tesla has
captured a large chunk of the ev market
share and has left both these companies
behind daimler has only recently
committed to an enormous 47 billion us
dollar investment in its ev capabilities
to catch up with tesla and toyota's ev
vision has leaned heavily on the site of
hydrogen fuel cell electric vehicles
given elon's views on hydrogen fuel
cells it is easy to deduce his opinion
on toyota's flagship hydrogen-powered
car the mirai to listen to a debate on
hydrogen fuel cells because i think that
they're extremely silly toyota's u.s and
canada sales of the mirai have only
totaled 9060 cars so far since its
launch in 2014. on the other hand tesla
delivered 201
250 cars in the second quarter of 2021
alone it is hard not to think that elon
was right all along it is fun to imagine
that as of october 2021 at 292 billion
us dollars elon musk's net worth is
almost 20 percent more than toyota's
overall valuation
apple car
now let's talk about the much hyped
apple electric car a good part of the
last decade was spent speculating over
whether apple would step into the ev
market with a tesla-like vehicle when
asked this question by an interviewer in
2016 this is what elon had to say i
think companies like apple will probably
make a compelling electric car
in april of 2021 apple ceo tim cook
finally hinted at their plans for an
autonomous electric vehicle that is
scheduled for launch in 2024. based on
another interview in 2018 we can see
that elon thinks apple missed the
opportunity to jump into the ev market
sooner why it's just like it's a missed
opportunity so even if apple manages to
produce a road tested electric vehicle
by 2024 by the time it goes into
production tesla would have moved leaps
and bounds ahead of them although elon
sounds modest in this interview it is
not hard for us to imagine that he
doesn't consider the apple car as a
serious competitor to tesla at least for
now google car
google's parent company alphabet also
owns a subsidiary called waymo that
develops autonomous driving cars however
for elon they don't feature in his list
of competitors for tesla as you can hear
him in this interview so i wouldn't say
you know google's a competitor because
they're not a car company
volkswagen
many see the vw id3 electric car that
went into production in 2019 as the only
major competition for the tesla model 3.
the more affordable tesla car it is also
an open secret that volkswagen aims to
overtake tesla as the world's largest ev
maker by 2025. this fact has not missed
elon's attention he and heber dice the
chairman of volkswagen group have always
shared a convivial relationship in
september 2020 it was reported that dice
hosted elon at braunschweig airport a
facility mostly used by volkswagen to
test drive the id3 and id4 electric cars
in the video released by volkswagen elon
can be seen driving the new cars and
asking all sorts of questions about his
performance
his first overall impression of the car
was good although he didn't quite like
the slow acceleration
neo
another competitor that elon musk
congratulated recently is chinese eevee
manufacturer neo he congratulated neo's
landmark milestone of rolling out its
100 thousandth vehicle off its
production line in april 2021 with a
tweet congrats to neo that's a tough
milestone the chinese ev market is
growing at a tremendous pace and by his
admission it is going to be tesla's
biggest marketplace of the future kind
of like i think long term will be uh our
biggest market up both where we make the
most number of vehicles companies like
neo xiao pung and saic volkswagen have
taken a significant portion of the
chinese ev market in recent years
byd
on the other hand a chinese ev
manufacturer that elon didn't take that
seriously back in 2011 was byd a company
in which warren buffett had invested
heavily as you can see in this interview
clip when asked about the chances of byd
becoming a significant force in the us
ev market he laughs
in a way elon got it both right and
wrong in gauging byd as a potential
competitor to tesla it is true that in
the u.s market byd is nowhere close to
tesla's market share however in china it
is a different story they are tesla's
major competitor there in september 2021
byd sold 36 606 battery electric
vehicles in china second only to tesla's
tally of 52 171
gm and ford motors
finally when it comes to elon's opinion
about the legacy car manufacturers in
america and their ev potential this clip
sums up his thought process nicely it's
tough you know for a company that's been
around for a century like as in the case
of gm there's just so much tradition and
ways of thinking and operating
i think it's very difficult this
organizational slowness and realizing
the potential behind a new opportunity
is what made these car manufacturers so
uncompetitive compared to tesla in the
ev sector today as elon himself said the
first step is to establish that
something is possible then probability
will occur but thankfully these giants
of the automotive world are slowly
waking up to a changing future gm
recently announced that it has plans to
build a chevrolet silverado ev with a
400 mile range but has given no release
date ford on the other hand has said it
will launch its ev truck next year dub
the ford f-150 lightning it will have a
range of up to 300 miles tesla as we
know has said it expects 250 plus miles
of range for its cyber truck there are
various other ev brands that are sure to
feature in elon musk's competition radar
like the mustang mach e audi e-tron bmw
i3 or the jaguar i-pace and we would
probably be here for a long time if we
go into all of them at the end of the
day we believe that elon sees electric
vehicles as the only alternative to our
current gas-guzzling transportation
market in that sense he has always
publicly welcomed competition he sees
tesla as a tool to catalyze the
automotive industry and speed up this
revolution by decades or more so there
we have it a comprehensive look at the
question what does elon musk have to say
about his competitors who do you think
is tesla and elon musk's main competitor
and do you think we will see the rise of
a similar giant in the ev market by the
end of this decade let us know in the
comments section below